foreign
's in Daytona Beach hi Catherine welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call how are you better than I deserve
what's up
so my question for you is
um it has to do with a credit score my
fiance and I are on baby step two we're
paying off debt we have one credit card
which I plan on paying off tomorrow and
then our car loan but
um
did both of you sign on the car
it's just me okay then you're a car loan
because you're not married yet it's not
our
okay correct when are you getting
married
um
I'm I'm thinking probably next year when
we can get out of debt and or when I can
get out of debt and we can cash flow in
the wedding
how much are you gonna spend on the
wedding
um I think we don't have a set budget
but we're going to go as budget friendly
as possible hopefully no more than like
three to five thousand yeah I would stop
everything and go get married
you think so huh I'm positive
it's going to increase your likelihood
of your relationship lasting it's going
to increase the uh the the how fast you
get out of debt and you get to wealth
building anyway why'd you call how can
we help
um yes so
um
my understanding
under side of the council we do have a
couple joint and we have a couple
individual
um like credit cards and everything and
get to that zero credit score before
trying to buy a home but we're just kind
of
bumping heads when it comes to that he
believes that we should you know keep
the credit lines open not use the cards
just in case of an emergency and have a
buffer until we can get our fully funded
emergency fund built up completely so I
guess my question is like
what what can I tell him to get him on
board and if so what would the process
be like and what kind of time frame how
old are you guys you look at closing out
those accounts
um I'm 23 he's 33.
mm-hmm
and what's his net worth
nothing
I don't have enough
he don't have any money
right
yeah so let's let's be clear we don't go
to a fat guy and ask him about physical
fitness so his opinion about this really
doesn't matter
because he's obviously wrong
am I wrong
he's broke
um you know so his theory is about money
suck
right
okay well do they or not I mean the
proof is in the pudding
he has no money so I mean when broke
people tell me their theories about
money it's laughable
it's when fat people tell me about how
to be physically fit it's the same thing
I have a keg if I go up to my uh on the
front of me my belly if I go up to my
personal trainer and he's got an eight
pack and I start telling him about
nutrition that's funny
you follow me
I'll follow him
here's the thing there's a lot of traps
that he's fallen into that are cultural
everyone believes this and using your
credit card as an emergency fund to
borrow at 21 interest is about the
stupidest thing you can do so let me
just give you some facts because he's in
kind of this wonky reality uh simulation
right now here's what happens if you
have an emergency above a thousand bucks
you pause the baby steps and you go
cover the emergency you sell stuff get
side jobs do whatever you have to do
so that covers that one right but that's
not the only reason you said the credit
score correct
right
there's a thing called manual
underwriting when you go to buy a house
and you get a no score loan through
manual underwriting they look at your
full Financial picture your income your
debt to income ratio your down payment
and they give you a mortgage without a
credit score
now he can he not believe it as if it's
I don't know the boogeyman or the Easter
Bunny but there's facts and data that
refute all of this and so I don't think
this is an intellectual discussion I
think this is a huge paradigm shift for
him to go oh I don't have to play the
games of a toxic money culture that says
borrowing is the key to wealth Catherine
you know why I was being so mean
why because she's 33 and you're 23 and I
think he's overbearing and I was trying
to give you some courage
he's wrong oh thank you
I think he's I think he's strutting
around like a turkey
and I think he's wrong and I want you to
stand up and and I want you to have your
voice in this relationship and both of
you have a vote because I think your
intellect is stronger than his on this
issue
and I don't think he thinks that am I
wrong just to be clear just to be clear
though we are not like coming at it in
an aggressive standpoint I just don't
want that image to come across I just
wanted to you're not coming at it in a
what's 10 points again
like an aggressive standpoint with each
other no I wasn't I wasn't saying that
but I don't I don't think he's listening
to you
okay I don't think it's aggressive at
all I think it's passive aggressive
possibly
but I mean I I really I mean I could be
wrong could be wrong maybe maybe you're
the overbearing one but that would be
unusual when your 10 years is Junior
it's possible I mean maybe you maybe
you're the stronger personality the two
that's possible but um that's why I was
doing that because I really want you to
I want your voice to be picked up in
this because I think he's discounting
your theories and it's making you
discount them and I think you're or your
theories or your approach the way you
want to handle this is not being heard
and he's kind of rolling his eyes like
little girl I got this
that's why I was doing that because I
I'm
I'm not okay with that process it's not
going to work out well for you
and I love both of you and I want you to
both to win and if he's on the phone I
would do the same exact thing so I want
you to I want you guys to you don't have
to be mean to each other or aggressive
with each other but his opinions are
wrong because he's broke
I I stand by my original statement but I
was being acerbic about it because I
really want to make sure that your voice
is being heard in this yeah and
Catherine I'm going to give you guys a
pre-marital counseling gift I don't know
that he's going to do it but I'm going
to gift you one year of Financial Peace
University I've got a class starting
next week that's virtual you can join
that or join a local class in your area
get in George's class he's a lot nicer
than me and maybe I can talk to him face
to face that'd be fun yeah George George
will be kind and helpful as opposed to
me so there you go that could help so
hang on the line and Austin will gift
you guys one year Financial Peace
sometimes David takes a third party you
know if it's just the two people going
at it together it can be difficult when
you have a third party I'm a third and
sometimes I'm a party sometimes he's a
fourth Dave's a lot he is a lot but Dave
I heard this quote the other day maybe
you're not too much maybe they're not
enough I thought that was a fun little
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom just
like that yeah so this is a common thing
in a relationship but guys honestly when
you're dealing with your family and
you're dealing with your friends or even
your spouse you know if your broke
friends
are making fun of your financial plan
it's a sign you're on track
it's like you lost 30 pounds and your
obese friend is making fun of you
that
good
means you're on track okay it means
you're doing the right thing and so I
you know I don't give people advice on
growing hair on top of my head I'm not
good at it my track record is horrible
and so if you call me up and ask me how
to grow hair on top of your head I you
should not take my advice Dave's good at
getting rid of that George however
George has the do
he has the do if you wanna if you want
to have the do you could ask George
about it because he's the he's the dude
nobody wants this much maintenance in
their life I don't have any maintenance
man my life is good but but I'm still
unqualified that's fair to give you
advice about growing hair on top one
thing I have on Dave there's nothing to
feel good nothing there I'm just saying
this is the Ramsay show